uh ladies and gentlemen our next speaker
is rory sutherland uh rory sutherland is
an award-winning advertis advertisement
chief he was educated at christ's
college he spent a probationary year
says here teaching classics at a grammar
school and then he went and joined ogle
me and mayther he was fired from there
from the planning department but then
joined the agency's creative department
as a junior copywriter and worked with
amongst others the fledgling microsoft
company uh he made his way up the
hierarchy he's now uh vice chairman of
the overall ogilvy group and was
recently elected president of the ipa he
writes a wikiman column at the spectator
he blogs and tweets ladies and gentlemen
rory sutherland
we're always a little uncomfortable i
think with anything new particularly
when we hit a certain age
point there's a brilliant private eye
cartoon from about 15 years ago which
actually illustrates this perfectly
actually illustrates roger's point which
just shows a small boy staring into the
flames of a fire outside a cave with his
grumpy father standing over him and
remarking when i was a boy we had to
make our own entertainment
douglas adams who would be a worthy
addition to this debate today made a
wonderful observation that actually
for any individual
technologies and inventions divide into
three
there are those that are invented before
you're about 10 which aren't technology
at all they're just infrastructure
none of us
none of us actually go oh [ __ ] the
bloody hot water's gone goddamn
technology okay
my children who are now ten when i first
took them away to a house in the country
for a weekend uh they turned on the
computer and their first reaction was
the internet's broken it had never
occurred to them that actually there was
a place without wi-fi
then you have those things which are
interesting which are those things which
are invented between the age of about 10
and about 35 and those are absolutely
magical wonderful glorious things
absolutely astounding i'm going to
actually rewrite my life around these
things can't imagine how we ever lived
without them
and then they're the third group of
things which are the things that are
invented
after you're about 45 which are utterly
ridiculous can't imagine what anybody
wants with this and what an absolutely
stupid idea and this this rule applies
no matter who you are
it's tragic i am 45
and i've reached exactly that point with
3d television
having bought absolutely everything that
skye could offer me up to that point i
look at 3d television and go
but why it reminds me interestingly a
comment on modernity made by fritz lang
the great cinema director who said of
cinema scope what on earth do you want
that for unless you're trying to show a
snake or a funeral
wide screen in its day was widely
attacked by people
and there's a problem i think we face
here which is that
first of all i'm making this case at a
festival which is an occasion where
everybody goes away for three days to
try and regain a kind of prelapsarian
paradise existence in a tent
um just a just a few caveats to this
these events i noticed always take place
in the summer
um the november festivals never seem to
do particularly
and everybody remembers to pack both
analgesics and a mobile phone
so the prelapse air in existence you
know is a little bit of but if you
phoned your dad he could end it all
um
that's the first
that's the first thing to remember you
know everybody hates a tourist
the second thing but the final question
to ask is actually you're not wrong
in seeking to actually enjoy a life with
actually less technology less noise etc
there's nothing wrong with this one of
the great things that free market
capitalism should recognize is that
actually subjective tastes matter
this is the great problem with marxism
it imposed technology on people whether
they wanted it or not the 1970s
bizarrely thought the highest form of
technological achievement was spending
three billion pounds of poor people's
money so that princess margaret could
get to barbados four hours earlier which
is the principal role of hong kong as
far as i could see the actual consumer
role was practically
the obsession with speed is a communist
one it's all about the aggrandizement of
the state not their grandest matter or
the improvement of the individual and
the highest form of course of that
marxist achievement was actually putting
a dog into space and leaving it there to
die
which which i think shows your ideal uh
your idea of technology in its most
peculiar light um but there's a one
vital thing there's only one vital
question asked nothing wrong with this
liking technology the only question
we've got to ask is
are we actually fair in our judgment of
it what are our biases when we hear the
word technology and we vote on this
motion what are the biases that are at
work that may be affecting the way we
think
and i think there's one vital thing to
understand which is that
any successful technology succeeds by
ceasing to be a technology
it becomes something we just grow up
with
and when we hear the word technology we
automatically think of ideas which are
in the process of being digested
and which are giving rise to some pain
cars were a technology in about 1910. in
the roman era sewage and a water supply
was a technology the really really
successful useful ones ceased to be
thought of as technology and when we
hear the word technology our attention
is disproportionately brought to bear on
those things that are difficult the
problems you mentioned harry are largely
problems in etiquette which with email
will be solved either by people ceasing
to use email or by people developing the
etiquette and subscribe this happened in
the early days of the telephone
alexander graham bell's advice which i
would actually like to read was that the
correct way to answer the telephone was
with a jaunty ahoy
for a long time uh with interestingly
anybody any checks here bizarrely his
advice in the czech republic stuck as
you ring a random number in prague this
evening your phone call will be answered
with ahoy
but the fact is those things will iron
themselves out but when we think of
technology the danger is that all our
focus is on those things that we're
currently wrestling with and not with
the things we've successfully digested
so the final question we've got to ask
is britain in a country where should we
pitch our affection for technology and
my concern is not that we should become
an absolutely i think they've been
periods of british history in the 1970s
anybody watching bbc four telly savalas
looks at birmingham
an extraordinary documentary from the
1970s that i think was a period where
optimism about the new particularly
modern architecture and roads just
reached this insane kind of height i'd
argue present-day china i'd also say at
present-day china where eight out of the
nine politburo are actually engineering
graduates
their idea of progress which is as far
as i can see from the air consists of
creating a giant version of acronym ohio
on a massive scale
doesn't seem to be absolutely brilliant
you know again high-speed trains and big
mega plexes form a large part of this
sort of state-sponsored technology but
at the same time all i want to make sure
of is that we also live in a country
which contemplates nuclear power as an
alternative to windmills france seems to
actually operate uh 85 of its electrical
devices uh on about 50 nuclear power
stations is this a completely insane
idea for the uk and what i don't want to
develop here is a culture which is the
opposite of the chinese culture which is
skeptical to technology in all but its
most uh uncontroversial and minimalistic
forms
and we can get the balance right it's
very important that britain does because
we're really rather good at it thanks
very much
thanks very much gentlemen your witness
um yes rory that was a that was a
brilliant speech i mean i i think your
point about aging uh is incredibly
powerful and being even older than you
um i have a terrible feeling that
at least i did i was thinking gosh rory
is absolutely right that's really then i
suddenly thought well there are all
these young people here and an awful lot
of them are actually very suspicious
about some of these new technologies so
it isn't just a question about aging um
so
i mean i i know people roughly your age
whose children are turning against these
technologies so um don't you think that
rather um goes against your point that
it's simply a matter of just being an
old
funny daddy i think it's actually very
good that people actually can use
technology they want and reject those
technologies they don't i think that
sort of top-down technology which you
see which is particularly characterized
by sort of grand projects of sort of
state-sponsored activity often benefit
the consumer very little in fact in in
markets one of the problems that marxism
had is it measured success by the
production of locomotives not by the
fact that any trains were actually
running
and so you could actually deem yourself
a successful economy simply by
manufacturing useless metal things now i
don't know i'm very pleased that
actually you know this continues this
actually technology's used to deliver
human benefits at an individual level um
i'm totally happy for people as part of
that to reject certain forms of
technology as a good winemaker well
after all the only vital thing is that
when we hear the word we don't react
viscerally as for example nuclear power
if it had been called anything other
than nuclear power the actual public
reactions are overly completely
different well perhaps also governments
and nuclear industries haven't been so
incredibly dishonest and opaque
throughout the world and covering up the
results of answers absolutely exactly
do you accept that the 250 million
chinese people who've been lifted out of
poverty over the past five years would
disagree with your
degradation of chinese uh progress no i
think i think i think the chinese
economy is making progress it's also uh
it's also a relatively easy thing to do
because it involves technology transfer
so basically you actually innovate
basically
what you're in favor of is western
middle middle-class use of technology
which allows you to play around with it
to have a certain kind of tv to reject
it for a weekend at a conference like
this but you're not really in favor of
millions upon millions of people being
lifted out of poverty by old
technologies which you consider rather
ruthless is that what it is it's simply
the fact that actually we've got to find
something to do with our money and
actually old technologies have a
diminishing marginal futility i don't
want four cars nor do i want a car that
goes 200 miles an hour but if we hadn't
gone through what china's going through
now which we went through in the
victorian era you wouldn't have the
choices that you were having no what i
mean so if we hadn't gone through the
old technology technological stuff which
was dirty and polluting and horrible and
filthy and it made people sick you
wouldn't have the luxury we're all
having now sitting in this lovely room
tweeting and texting why shouldn't china
also go through the old technological
revolution
without criticisms from the west about
them doing it the wrong way ah there's
another question there which is indians
frequently and possibly wrongly believe
it's possible to go to the third stage
of industrial development without going
through the second one and that is
widely positive in india whether that's
true or not i don't know but it's true
it's true in africa where they've
completely left over the old telegraph
system that just adopted mobile phones
yeah with great success and very
economic contribution
yeah very good ladies and gentlemen
please thank our panelists
you